so here's the other here's the other
thing was interesting so we've got a
little Ponzi scheme which is I probably
lost half the viewers so far you got a
you got a little Ponzi scheme I'm gonna
wrap it up here here this is a short
podcast yes this is we're like halfway
only 40 minutes I don't have to do that
to eat after this I had an I had a small
omelet at a 520 calories omelet got your
calories it says it right yeah really
bro I'm look at it why don't I look I'm
[ __ ] amazing
are you are you keto I don't know what
keto is all right keys key to keep going
um okay so I don't want to say some
stuff right now
anyway no the point is listen do you
remember pfg yes I remember trading
under PFT PFT who is the guy who was the
CEO pfg again loosened or loosened or
Russell loosened or right okay so we've
got all our money a bunch of mutton on
Oliver oh I've got a bunch of money in
pfg and they do a margin call and it
wipes us out yeah well pfg was a Ponzi
scheme what it was a two three or four
hundred million dollar Ponzi scheme is
one of the largest Ponzi schemes for it
one largest it was the largest Forex
Ponzi scheme ever gotta be yeah for that
much money so they didn't trade a
[ __ ] thing Russell Wilson Dorf didn't
trade us own a millions he know this no
no Blaine he's doing side deals with
them the truth is he's thinking he's
convincing like a legitimate guy to help
[ __ ] siphon money and do that no he's
not this guy's a crook so it is like the
Russian doll got played Russia is
playing everybody like that comparison I
love Paris it's the little Ponzi scheme
and the bigger Ponzi scheme and then the
huge Ponzi scheme on top of this is
three Ponzi schemes one on top of just
living in the bowels of the bigger Ponzi
jails right in prison no sir no
thesaurus came up with balls okay so
that's completely untrue I did have with
the SARS but I didn't have spellcheck or
anything so listen okay so Wars and
dwarf here's the problem with moose
Dorf Wuzhen Dorf has been running a pot
how do you run like a [ __ ] half a
billion dollar ponzi scheme for is it
twenty years he's been doing it it's a
little bit sharper than Blaine a little
sharper than Blaine here's how he does
just doing the same thing just yeah yeah
so he's ripping off businesses other
businesses he's ripping off in Hansie
schemes not just you know friends with
money yeah he's ripping off people like
like a capital blue right he's like a
made of right so exactly so what happens
is and where we're I'm sorry but where
was it where was pfg located where was
they where were they based out of
Chicago Chicago right I feel like so
many Ponzi schemes were in Florida
Florida's filled with a lot of criminals
like I'm at a ton of like like the
financial criminals yeah we're the
vitality story a total meant yeah we're
he's raising all the money he said
listen he go you go to Palm Beach area
and he said man he said it's [ __ ]
inundate he said everybody who meets a
[ __ ] is a scam artist so many stories
I've heard of Ponzi schemes getting
busted and during the financial crisis
in 2008 yeah and however they rot
Florida like but they're running forever
so you're running five years you're like
yeah everything's great and then the
economy takes a huge correction and you
go and it just destroys your whole
[ __ ] thing you could go forever how
long yeah right what if they're like
Madoff it had Madoff could have gone
forever he'd gone for like [ __ ] 15 or
20 years I know guys that have gone
[ __ ] 10 15 years on Ponzi schemes and
had in that one correction they don't
[ __ ] account for that and then
everybody says oh I'm scared give me my
money back they're like about that money
my bad so alright so loosened or fear so
likable here's the oops
I feel bad so listen here's what was
said Dorf does he's all the money he's
trading is through US bank so all them
all his accounts were US bank accounts
there they're handling everything this
is nothing by the way he's not trading
anything he's just stealing the money
he's blown
200 million here he's lost just tons of
money uh over 200 million was gone
including capital ooh money six million
I mean this guy nearly half a billion
dollars had flowed through efg gone so
here's the problem he's going to keep
going he could just keep going and going
the problem is is that the CFTC changes
their reporting status he he had
reported to pfg all the paperwork that
comes in to the bank that has to be
filled out by bank officials was all
going to a p.o box he had opened in the
name of US bank so the CFTC is mailing
these reports to his to his p.o box he's
filling a mountain sending them back
yeah now they're gonna do it
electronically directly to the bank so
they're not going to be fooled by the
PIO box
all right so he realizes it's over in
like a couple of days they're gonna
report and they're gonna know that I'm
supposed to have 300 million dollars in
the bank and I've actually only got six
million it's over I'm done so he does
what any good Ponzi scheme person should
do
he gets a car and he gets a home not a
touch and he come he tries to commit
suicide oh should do should do oh he
gets the hose and he puts it in and he
does the thing and he puts it in the
pipe and he duct tapes it up and he cuts
a little slit you know the only part
that bothers me about his his uh his
suicide attempt is that he's driving uh
he's driving like a Chevy Cavalier or
something I mean nobody deserves to die
in a Chevy cab I mean you've got six
million dollars you can Bentley maybe
had some sort of sentimental value to
him it's just ridiculous yeah that's
true that maybe it was maybe it was his
first car or something yeah I'm good if
I'm doing that it's going to be inside
so he takes a handful of pills
he drinks down some liquor he writes a
letter explaining that he hasn't made
any trades all the money's gone
everything please a front thing starts
the car yeah [ __ ] he's hardcore bro
he's going out and and it would have
worked out I wouldn't call that hardcore
well he's not sick kind of gun in his in
his head I wrote one story about a guy
that took a gun and stuck it in his head
and pulled the trigger and it didn't
kill him so then hooked him up blew
through his [ __ ] eye cavities and so
now he's blind laying there on the
ground to find the gun club now he's got
to find the [ __ ] gun and shoot
himself again he killed himself the
second time back to Wuzhen Dorf
rosendorf would have killed himself
except one of his employees really
enjoyed his job and he showed up about
an hour early and found his boss in the
back parking lot in a stuff passed out
he goes he opens the door and looked up
company's little [ __ ] up and maybe
they do ties he'll the owner the
company's at a [ __ ] cavalier so so he
killed his buzz yep so he wakes up in
the hospital yeah he's got his worst
nightmare case scenario folks have been
wake up in the hospital handcuffed to
the bed yeah yeah they gave him a chunk
of time and you just snitched yourself
out in a letter on top of it oh oh yeah
so Wilson doors already like 70 by the
way they gave him oh he been running a
Ponzi scheme for 20 years
pfg was a 20-year pawn he was 50 not too
bad um it was three hundred and seventy
six million dollars it was late for you
kids thirteen hundred ambassadors he
blown through 115 million [ __ ] what did
they end up giving him damn it they gave
him like a chunk of time wasn't doable
for a guy who was like 65 or 70 anyway
so he's dying in jail
so uh what else happens Blaine's in
prison oh yeah the trial
Donovan goes it goes to trial I like to
point out that you've been no help at
all
[Laughter]